hey guys this is vadim with max tech and
in today's video
what i have right here is two dell xps
13s
this one is the brand new xps 13
the 9310 this has intel's 11th
generation processor with the built-in
intel xe graphics which is super
powerful and this one right here has
intel's 10th generation i7
with the g7 graphics so it was the best
graphics
on the 10 gen and this is the best
graphics on
the 11 channel and this is actually an
i5 but it performs
very well as you guys are just about to
see so what we're gonna do
in this video is run some gaming
benchmarks and then get into some
actual gaming to see if there's a big
difference between the tension and 11
gen chips
and to see if the intel xe graphics is
good enough to actually play
decently well with decent fps on this
super
thin and light premium laptop so let's
get right into it as you guys see from
that top camera above
the sony a7s 3 with 4k 60 recording
we've got unigine heaven on both of
these machines
we're doing the extreme preset like we
always do
for some reason the scaling is horrible
but let's go ahead and run this
and we'll get the benchmark started here
in just a second
now it's funny because i already see a
ton of drop frames on the older xps
where here everything is super smooth at
least much more smooth compared to the
old one that's very interesting
especially in this scene right here you
guys can just see so many dropped frames
on the older xps and this looks very
smooth
all right there you guys have it we have
our scores back and that's actually
pretty impressive we've got
17.6 on the old xps and 25.9
fps average on the new one with a
maximum fps
of 59.8 and 41.9
on the other one so that's a pretty big
improvement especially since
last year's 10 gen the graphics on that
model were significantly more powerful
than
the previous model before that so within
two years or two generations
this is really impressive by intel now
let's get into a quick
geekbench 5 opencl graphics test we've
got the tension here in the 11th channel
let's run it real quick
all right there we have our scores and
as you can see basically 40
higher with the new intel xe graphics
it's actually pretty impressive honestly
all right now with those benchmarks done
let's jump into some gaming
now we actually tried to run black ops
cold war beta
but we got error messages it wouldn't
run we're going to be playing some
fortnight but before we begin i want to
mention that
max is actually going to be doing a
video comparing the 10 gen
and 11 gen he's going to be testing the
video editing performance
photo editing other stuff like that so
definitely subscribe so you see that
video
alright we're starting off with the 10th
gen chip the i7
on the previous xps 13 of course we've
got the
mx master wireless mouse right here so
i'm turning off the frame rate limit
i've set it to full screen
we've got a little bit more than 1080p
so 1920 by 1200 because it's 16
by nine and we've got everything set to
high so let's see how this does show fps
is on motion blur is off
let's do this i'm getting into a solo
match now what i'm going to be doing is
testing out the exact same settings
on the new 11 gen xps all right here we
go and this is pretty bad
i'm dropping frames all over the place
this is
horrible 10 fps 9 fps this is completely
unplayable all right i'm getting about
15 16 right now drop down to 10.
this is unplayable at these settings
better not grab a gun bro
oh it's probably a bot
oh step oh the drop frames man it's the
drop frames
let's keep it at this resolution i'm
gonna drop it down to
i don't know let's just go low but we're
gonna keep the 3d res
at 100 to make sure we're still at that
same resolution
it's doing better it's doing better for
sure we're still experiencing a little
bit of drop frames but we're running at
a pretty consistent
45 fps that's much better now that we're
at low graphics
i might try to turn it down a little bit
to see
the graphic settings that we need to get
60 fps
yeah right now we're getting about 35
fps sometimes dipping down to 30.
it's not optimal but i mean on this
thing it's not bad
and remember guys this is the older 10th
generation
i7 chip so i'm very curious to see how
the 11th gen is going to do
the drop frames man no sometimes it does
dip down i mean it
got down to like 20 right there 27 30.
right i'm going back into the settings
since i have everything on low already
let's turn it down 1680
by 10.50 so that's probably a little bit
less than 1080p man i could see all that
aliasing
of those hills right over there so it
looks like that didn't really do
anything we're still at like 30
35 fps all right let's go down oh man
this is almost like 720p 1280 by 800.
all right so i've set the resolution all
the way down it's still at like 30 fords
i don't know what's going on but it
cannot handle
this game i don't know what's i don't
know what's up with it this is really
weird maybe it's the
vram the highest fps i saw was 53 but
that was for a split second now we're
getting around 40
30 sometimes in the 20s
oh grenade all right i mean it's still
playable but
not really i mean maybe it's the heat
you know this is a very thin
very thin laptop maybe that's why so i
think what we're gonna do
is we're gonna switch over to the 11 gen
right there
here we are on the 11th gen xps 13
9310 and i can already feel
that it is performing better than the
old one let's go into those settings
let's do
full screen we'll do 1920x1200
take off this limit just like that
everything is on high
3d res we're set into 100 we're gonna
try out high
just like we did last time 19 fps right
now but i'm not really doing anything
everything does look really good but at
19
20 fps it's just it's not going to cut
it
this fps is not doing it oh he's fast
yeah i'm not getting enough fps let's
turn it down to this setting and let's
go down to low just like we did last
time we got low and a little bit less
fps 1680 by 1050. oh 3d res we got to
turn up hey this is actually doing a
little bit better
i mean i'm getting over 40 fps now
of course some frame drops here and
there but 47 fps right there
no don't let me die
that's so bad i almost died to this dude
let's match the settings that we had
before
1280 by 800 100 3d res
everything turned down i'm instantly
seeing a graphics quality
dip and just like before the fps isn't
really going up much
and i guess playing fortnite on this
thin and light laptop oh look at that 65
right there
hey this might actually be able to play
this
let's get this dude oh snap i'm scared
that guy was good
what's up bubba anyway we just hit
65 fps that's not bad at all we did have
to turn the settings all the way down to
like almost
720p with everything down to low
but if you just want to play fortnite on
this thing you're going to turn
everything down trying to get 60 fps so
not too bad all right well there you
guys have it so what did we learn from
this video well
obviously the intel xe graphics is
around 40
faster than the previous best that intel
had for integrated graphics and
within this game the 10th generation
model the xps
even if you turn up everything all the
way down you're really not getting close
to a decent experience whereas here
even when we didn't turn the resolution
all the way down we could still get
around 45 fps which was pretty decent
but when we turned everything down
everything started getting a little bit
smoother we'd get about
65 fps sometimes with dips going down to
45 sometimes 30 but if you want to get
this dell xps it's
probably one of the best windows laptops
out there
super thin super light you'll know that
if you want to do a little bit of gaming
you can get this thing with the intel xe
graphics integrated
you have to turn all the settings down
but you can at least get a
almost 60 fps gaming experience you
definitely don't get perfectly smooth
with the integrated graphics but
you almost get there so if somebody
really wanted to
they could buy this thing and play some
games with it so hopefully you guys
enjoy this video and by the way if
you're not already subscribed click that
circle above because max is going to be
doing a
comparison video with the 10th
generation and the 11
comparing everything in terms of
performance video editing
all that kind of stuff so definitely
subscribe for that and check out one of
those two videos right over there thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next video
[Music]